en el centro de detención dandong en el
noreste de china el embajador de canadá
presenció la resolución del juicio por
espionaje de michaels space ver el
veredicto para el canadiense culpable la
sentencia 11 años
condenamos en los términos más fuertes
esta decisión ya que en el proceso legal
faltó justicia y transparencia nuestros
pensamientos están con michael y su
familia en estos momentos difíciles
el empresario es paper y su compañero el
expatriado michael coke un ex
diplomático fueron arrestados en 2018
por cargos de espionaje desde entonces
se encuentran en aislamiento sin tener
casi ningún tipo de contacto con el
mundo exterior
el arresto llegó poco tiempo después de
que canadá detuviera mengüen show
directora financiera de la gigante
empresa tecnológica huawei con orden de
extradición a eeuu por violaciones
potenciales de las sanciones impuestas
sobre irán beijing ha solicitado su
liberación en repetidas ocasiones y ha
dicho que su detención es parte de un
ataque estadounidense sobre el
desarrollo tecnológico chino los
críticos de china han descrito las
recientes acusaciones contra canadienses
como un tema de rehenes políticos
mientras que la relación entre beijing y
ottawa toca su punto más bajo la
decisión del miércoles llegó un día
después de que una corte separatista
china rechazó una apelación del
canadiense robert schellenberg cuya
condena de 15 años en prisión por
tráfico de drogas fue repentinamente
aumentada la pena de muerte tras el
arresto de men wenzhou